Mr Speaker the labor party is proud to
be the party of the Good Friday
agreement and peace and prosperity in
Northern Ireland we welcome attempts to
make the protocol work more effectively
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that it has been poorly implemented and
that the basis for any deal must be
removing unnecessary checks on Goods
Prime Minister well Mr Mr Speaker let me
welcome the uh on related to her place
and associate myself with the remarks of
The Honorable gentleman about Nicola
Bully's family our thoughts are of
course with them as he knows we are
still in active discussions with the
European Union but he should know that I
am a conservative of brexiter and a
unionist in any agreement that we reach
needs to tick all three boxes it needs
to ensure sovereignty
for Northern Ireland and it's a
safeguard Northern Ireland's place in
our Union and it needs to find practical
solutions to the problems faced by
people and businesses I will be Resolute
in fighting for what is best for
Northern Ireland and the United Kingdom
Mr Speaker we all agree that the
protocol can be improved
but there are trade-offs and we need to
face up to them his predecessor told
businesses that there would be no forms
no checks no barriers of any kind that
was absolute nonsense and it destroyed
trust so in the interest of restoring
that trust trust will he confirm that to
avoid a hard border on the island of
Ireland the deal he's negotiating is
going to see Northern Ireland continue
to follow some EU law
Mr Speaker I think that the honorable
gentleman is jumping ahead we are still
we we are still
[Applause]
we are still in intensive intensive
discussions with the European Union to
ensure that we can find agreement that
meets the test that I said and that is
sovereignty for Northern Ireland it's
Northern Ireland's place in our precious
Union and it is to find practical
solutions to the problems faced by
people and businesses I have spent time
engaging and listening to those
communities in Northern Ireland
businesses and political parties I have
a good understanding of what is required
and I will keep fighting until we get it
thank you
Mr Speaker the prime minister is biting
his tongue but at some point the
irreconcilables on his benches are going
to Twig and they're going to come after
him the former trade Minister says there
can be no role for the European court of
justice in Northern Ireland
so will the Prime Minister be honest
with them and tell them that's not going
to happen Mr
Mr Mr speaker now again we need to keep
going to actually secure an acceptable
agreement but for the honorable
gentleman to be talking about a deal
that he hasn't even seen that with
[Applause]
usual position when it comes to the
European Union it's it's give the EU a
blank check and agree to anything they
offer
it's not it's not a strategy Mr Speaker
that's surrender
Mr Speaker
it's not my question says avoiding it's
their question so he's avoiding
his predecessors wasted months pushing
the Northern Ireland protocol Bill if
implemented it would tie us up in
battles with the EU the United States
and others at precisely the time we
should be building common ground to
boost our economy and show Unity against
Putin now the Prime Minister clearly
wants a closer relationship with the EU
so can he confirm that if there's a deal
he will pull the protocol bill
prime minister Mr Speaker look what the
The Honorable gentleman wants to put the
EU first I want to put Northern Ireland
first
questions on on these questions The
Honorable gentleman said he would
respect the result of the referendum and
then he promised to back a second one
all the while he was constantly voting
to frustrate brexit and I know what the
British people know that on this
question he can't be trusted to stick up
for Britain
Mr Speaker the sound you hear is them
cheering the Prime Minister pulling the
wool over their eyes
[Applause]
the fifth anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement the 30th anniversary of the
Downing Street declaration Tony Blair
and John Major both recognized that
politics in Northern Ireland is built on
trust and not telling people what they
want to hear and the need to take
seriously the concerns of both
communities nationalists and unionists
it's vital their voices are herd so can
the Prime Minister confirm that whatever
deal he brings back this house will get
a vote on it
prime minister Mr Speaker of course of
course Parliament will express its view
but what is crucial but what what is
crucial here
what is crucial here is that is this not
this is not about his desire to play
political games in this house with this
situation this is about what is best for
the people and communities of Northern
Ireland
and that Mr Speaker is what I will keep
fighting for
well Mr Speaker I take it from that that
this house will get a vote and I look
forward to that vote in due course
because everyone knows the basis of this
deal has been agreed for weeks but it's
the same old Story the country has to
wait while he plucks up the courage to
take home the malcontents The Reckless
the Wreckers on his own benches but I'm
here to tell him he doesn't need to
worry about that because we will put
country before party
[Music]
[Applause]
accept our offer ignore the house of
indignation from those on his side who
will never take yes for an answer why
doesn't he just get on with it
and it's Mr Speaker Mr Speaker what what
I'm doing is talking and listening to
the people of Northern Ireland that is
the right thing to do it's to make sure
that we can respond and resolve to the
concerns of the unious communities and
businesses in Northern Ireland and that
is what I will keep doing but Mr Speaker
we know that the 100 General talks about
his plans we have heard that tomorrow
he's going to announce five missions but
we all we all we already know what they
are it's uncontrolled immigration it's
Reckless spending it's higher debt and
it's softer sentences and for the fifth
pledge the fifth pledge Mr Speaker we
all know it's that he reserves the right
to change his mind on the other four
happens